like this is what should have been
stuffed into samosa earlier to me kind
of tastes like refried black beans
the flavor is off man I feel like it's
the flour that's what's wrong with it I
would have
[Music]
hey I'm Jenny hey I'm 10 a.m. 3 and
today we're gonna be trying Indian food
from Trader Joe's
I love Trader Joe's the only thing I
think I've tried is a masala burger
right I would say I do like 90% of my
groceries at Trader Joe's I recently
discovered Trader Joe's but I'm a huge
fan recently recently I thought it was
way too boozy for me to be honest I
would probably expect the Indian food to
be like all right or decent good to have
like as a go-to and you don't feel like
cooking it wouldn't be my first choice
for Indian food
I'm Guyanese on West Indian so I'm
Caribbean actually so like I didn't grow
up with my parents make an Indian food
West Indian food is different than an
Indian Indian food I just really love my
dad's cooking but I can't get that here
in California so I try and go back and
eat it at home I've never bought like a
microwavable thankful Trader Joe's yeah
I just want to get my groceries but I
feel like you know Trader Joe's hasn't
let me down yet so I want to give him
the benefit of the doubt I think they're
gonna stock up yeah they're tiny they're
tiny little small so guys this one's a
little follow your party but that's fine
got samosas in a little yeah they oh man
these look dope bite-sized samosa yeah
they're not like the big ones that you
yeah I feel like those are like more
standard yeah having bigger ones but
anytime I see like a frozen one they're
always a little late it smells good yeah
we got to do the cheers cheers Cheers
okay sweet somewhat right not spicy at
all yeah good flavor mm-hmm this was
spice to it whatever but when you pop
into a restaurant when people makes the
most a lot of time they're big yeah
they're really fat they're usually
samosas are about like that and when you
bite it when you bite into them it's a
lot going on so this is easier to just
kind of pop in here but I was like
American party food when you want to
show your friends like I like Dan sighs
yeah you're just shocking mm-hmm I
didn't very good trainers to nail it
yeah give like the inside the strong
point the outside is like all right they
did a really good job in the inside the
outside is a bit thin it's kind of
squishy it would usually be kind of like
crispy on the outside and fluffy on the
inside the filling was ya know missin
the masalas pretty good at air like this
is probably my good level of spice like
it's got a limb
very little bit of a kick which is good
for me like normally I feel like you go
into Indian restaurant you ask them for
the mild like their Myles is like my leg
danger zone I would eat it again sure
wait yeah yeah thanks yeah nothing
compares to the real thing though
there's mad different types of Indian
bread as one we already got none Parata
wrote like Guyanese people we Matt wrote
eat like that looks like roti yeah let's
see what's up
is this supposed to be a lot chocolate
uh-huh like this is way better in the
preparation feel better yeah it was
better yeah it looks like it's supposed
to be some sort of Baraka oily this is a
perfect way that no this is pretty solid
it's like it it's not like the real
thing but I also like it flakiness just
soft this like this is always gonna be
paired with something right normally
people wouldn't eat this myself like
this I was vicious and I'm not being a
lettuce yeah so yeah not authentic not
how my mom makes it but good like
somebody like me like I've actually
never attempted to make rotis and so I
would prefer just you know probably
eating this up - yeah this would be a
good thing to keep in my freezer if I
had Indian food and I just need like
that bread to go with it mm-hmm I feel
like Trader Joe's didn't really do
anything wrong here they got it right
for solid intent for sure yep what
purchase no anything that's fried bread
is I'm gonna like it I will take this
out way yeah when I'm leaving a meeting
bus this is the veggie masala burger
right so I'm gonna really use a fork
come on I don't know if it's gonna be a
little this is Indian people doing you
raise your hand you're right
I'm just gonna forget it this looks like
a masala burger to me miss allenbury I
know that specific way from Trader Joe's
yes but not from like any sort of
traditional cooking I know it's like the
McDonald's of like yeah so if you like
actually and if you go to McDonald's in
India they got they they have this they
literally have this it's crazy
yeah the spices that are in there you've
got chunks of potato looks like carrot
what I like about it is like it's a good
veggie burger it's good it's different
but you don't see this in India my mom
never made this she would make like the
tail this even though it wasn't
authentic I'd probably eat it again
right short right now yeah like solid
nine evidently these are nons this looks
like fluffy delicious
bread but I would not call that non
bootleg non yeah it is not as looking
bootleg this looks more PD yeah is that
we're supposed to be they're supposed to
be not like that's what it said on the
package I don't know that this has been
made properly in a thumb door hmm
definitely not let's see what's up by
itself it tastes not like traditional
non I'm it's soft it's chill it's chill
I mean I don't know it this is more
business this yeah nor Pete the
aesthetic is not really like I don't
know if I'm nan looks different yeah
like nan is like more wider and like odd
shape it doesn't taste bad no it's not
bad it's solid but yeah definitely not
not yeah mmm really smell like anything
but it it looks good it is dull clearly
okay some banner of lentil dish and
legumes it looks promising
yeah and based on the toilet before that
was really quite good for frozen food I
feel like it could be good but then
again I don't smell anything I feel like
I smell a lot more not spicy enough they
get a little bit too smooth yeah that's
right strange to me it kind of tastes
like refried black beans
I feel the flavor is off man tradition
it should be a spicier thing but even if
you got it mild the flavor is not really
kicking it's good for what it is
this is Trader Joe's cake hmm in a way
that I would have expected but slightly
better this is like brown open that's
nothing right I would never recommend
this to anybody ever
no not gonna be included I don't think I
would do that with ya this is brown goop
smells good
that smells great right I think it was
like it's more like II tomatoey yeah I
see is that some kind of chickpeas like
China yeah this looks like China Hana
masala maybe I washed my hands I'll go
this way more authentic first yeah man
doesn't even know I feel like it's
missing a certain masala and I can't
place what it is but it doesn't have it
you would go to an Indian restaurant and
fried by this like I would be shocked
that some if someone told me that they
bought this reserved oh yeah I have to
agree this is really good and I don't
even like South China I'm pleasantly
surprised by this I just thought it
would be sold yeah it's definitely very
salty but I'm liking it and it's not
I would find like it as a traditionally
cooked a dish I would I would definitely
recommend this for an Indian person by
many my pops is all about South China
and I think he would that would be yeah
this was solid
mmm what's more so that's a good start
okay so it's most Christmassy I would
just like holidays is this like holiday
chai cuz I could put that I like the
holidays this is the right color but it
smells like cinnamon just the smell of
this drink doesn't smell like an Indian
chai this smells like a Christmas cha
yes exactly it tastes like school
chocolate milk we mix with cinnamon this
actually tastes good yeah but it doesn't
taste like chai this is not masala chai
no not masala chai at all you know this
is like probably from a packet and you
just poured some milk on it and gave it
to us even if you go to an Indian
restaurant they would not serve this for
sure I would definitely drink this it's
creamy it's sweet and it's got spices in
it if you're looking for winter
wonderland in a cup this is a few Regis
a decent beverage it's just not chai
like I I would I could drink this as a
holiday beverage like if sorry Starbucks
put like some kind of a holiday name on
this like you know winter extravaganza
I would cop it a happily yeah but it's
just no I'd be okay yeah yes not it's
not China though yeah I think it was
pretty good all in all I would give it
like a 7 out of 10
cuz they nailed a lot of aspects when it
comes to Indian food I give it like a 6
point 5 out of 10 at a total if we go
and offer like authenticity and flavor
and all that I'd say 7 yeah well I
definitely will copy our roti again yeah
cuz you don't expect that mhmmm like
yeah I wasn't food definitely yeah you
definitely have a bit lower expectation
so they were definitely exceeded so far
Trader Joe's is today that's correct has
never led me astray so I think this is
consistent with the Trader Joe's brand
you did pretty good yeah for it yes
you
[Music]